We need to consider a few issues
when we use RSA in practice.
First, for
given key the same plain text message
will always be encrypted
into same ciphertext.
A related issue is that for
some special-case plaintexts,
such as zero, one or minus one,
the ciphertexts are always zero,
one or minus one regardless of the keys.
These shortcomings allow
the attacker to know
the plaintext even though
he doesn't know the key.
Another issue is that RSA is manageable.
That is if the attacker transforms
a ciphertext into another, it would
produce a predictable transformation
of the decrypted plaintext.
Suppose Bob sends Alice a encrypted
message using Alice's public key.
The attacker intercepts the ciphertext.
Then the attacker
changes the ciphertext.
Then when Bob receives
this modified ciphertext,
he's going to decrypt it
as s times m instead of m.
That is, the attacker has the ability to
change the ciphertext in such a way that
it would produce predictable
effect on the decrypted plaintext.
In this case, the plain text
is increased by a factor of S.
In practice,
the standard uses some sort of padding.
That is, add some random
bytes as prefix to m, and
this addresses the issues
that we just discussed.